حرب النوويه قريبه لحوح الافق حيث اثار
اعلنوا بريطانيا عن خطه لارسال ذخيره
تحتوي على اليورانيوم المستنفذ لاستخدامها
في اوكرانيا اثار غضب روسيا الرئيس روسيا
فلاديمير بوتين هدد بالرد وقال ان روسيا
ستكون مضطره للرد في حال تزويد اوكرانيا
بهذه القذائف فيما حذر وزير الدفاع
من صدام النووي محتمل قائلا ان خطوات اقل
متبقيه قبل حدوث صدام نووي محتمل بين
روسيا والغرب بدوره اكد وزير الخارجيه
ان تمت ستصاعد الموقف الى مستويات جديده
وخطيره وستؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه على علاقات
البلدين
هذه خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد نحو تصعيد
خطير وكمي وصدرت تصريحات لبعض المسؤولين
الغربيين يقولون فيها انه لا يوجد شيء
مخيف في ذلك وان قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
لم تكن محظوره وانهم لا يخالفون اي
اتفاقيات لكن الجميع يتذكر نتائج استخدام
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم في يوغسلافيا
والعراق عندما اصيب عشرات الالاف من
المدنيين وجنود الناتو الذين استخدموا
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم تلك